foreign
attempts about seven years ago I feel
like it connects to me being more
cynical about the world and I want to
change that but you haven't touched the
core issue why is there a ticker tape on
the story of your life that runs
underneath everything that goes on in
your world
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
show about your relationships and your
mental health and your marriage and
whatever else you got going on your kids
summer vacation whatever it is I'm here
to walk alongside you this show's about
real people going through real things in
real time and I promise that I'm going
to sit with you I'm gonna tell the truth
and we're going to figure out what we're
gonna do next do you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k don't forget best supplements
on the planet in my opinion and only in
my opinion go to Thorn t-h-o-r-n-e
thorne.com you the letter u
slash deloni for 25 off all right let's
go out to Detroit and talk to B what is
up B
hi John how's it going ah dude
incredible how are you oh good just
wonderful
just wonderful good great grand
good I'm glad you did wonderful what's
up how can I help
um okay so I just started dating this
awesome guy
um we've almost been dating for like
five months
um he's super in to his career and
getting it going he's 28
um and recently he was away on a
business trip for about two weeks and he
told me that he might in the future on
the future business trip have to take
girls out to dinner
um to secure business deals
and I was like I don't like that so so I
guess my question is is it is it normal
for this kind of thing to happen in the
business world if you're in sales to
like take I mean I I know men like take
other men out to dinner to like secure
sales and stuff and like buy them dinner
but I didn't know that like guys took
girls out too so
yeah it's it's
there's a whole host of things here I'm
interested what was his response when
you said hey that makes me uncomfortable
um
I he said it was strictly about business
um and he didn't understand that I was
upset
um he said that he felt like it was a
trust thing and I needed to trust him
um and he said he thought that I was
being overly dramatic and like bringing
in security baggage into a relationship
um
so yeah
all right lots of things here
give me one or two direct questions
because there's a lot going on here
well as he he doesn't understand why I'm
upset for him taking like a girl
from his like
um customer like one of the places he's
at one of the customers that's a girl
taking her out like a she's a client to
dinner and like buying her dinner and
that's just them to one-on-one yeah so
um to answer your question yes it is
common happens all the time colleagues
go out and you're not crazy
not even a tiny little bit
okay so I did
um I did I did this all the time in my
former life when I was in academics but
it was with
um academic colleagues
and 100 of the time
I texted my wife and let her know and I
texted my wife when it was over
not ever going to cheat on my wife but
man it was important for I didn't ever
want someone to come up to her and be
like hey I saw John was so and so I saw
him with this woman at lunch today so
that's what I'm worried about well hold
on so number one there was always that
level of communication there was never
any any and that was me trying to honor
my wife okay and there's just there was
a reality to the business I was in
and
it made for problems
uh-huh I ended up really really liking
spending time with people
that were not my wife I craved there
laughing at my jokes I craved them
wanting to hang it right so it was not
smart on my part
and so I think it's wise
oh and also let me just say this we live
in a world unfortunately where
there's
um there's been a shift in guilty until
proven innocent
so if somebody walks away from some of
these exchanges and just says hey this
person offered me this said this it can
create some mess and so I I now I just I
just always have somebody with me that's
just that's just a personal thing on my
end and I know I can get grief like that
I'm not being Equitable and I'm treating
people differently I'm trying to be wise
for me from my wife for my family for my
business wisdom globally
and I've never ever had a what I would
call a sales experience or a client
interaction
that wasn't bolstered by having somebody
else in the room
yeah I've just never had that so that's
number one
and number two it does cause problems
here's the bigger issue for me
I know I have friends of mine dear
friends close great friends that are
women
that wouldn't care one like two days
from Sunday if their husband was out
doing sales calls a woman wouldn't even
wouldn't even think about it yeah what
do you enter their mind and I've got
friends who are like you makes them very
uncomfortable that my husband's gone for
two weeks or my boyfriend's gone for two
weeks in four states over and every
night of the week he's with the same or
one or two women like that they feel
uncomfortable by that here's my concern
for your relationship right now
that at the res after receiving how you
feel about something
the guy that you started this call by
saying he's an awesome guy he's so great
and so wonderful
immediately made you stupid for having a
Feeling
and I don't like that at all
you're allowed to have your feelings and
if it makes you uncomfortable
then as somebody who honors you and
wants to be with you for a long time and
treat you with dignity and respect he is
going to look at his environment and see
if there are ways that he can honor the
person he's saying he loves
see what I'm saying yeah that makes
sense and so I don't like whether it's
right or wrong I I have the way I choose
to do it now that's just me I also
um I'm not gonna beat anybody else up
you're gonna make your own decisions I
think I've
put myself in situations that weren't
wise and it's just I I have some pretty
clear boundaries now so be it yeah
what I'm more concerned with your
relationship is you said hey I'm
uncomfortable with this hey I don't like
this and he said you're stupid
and B you're not
yeah can I ask you a harder question
okay you have other trust issues in this
relationship no
um
so yeah okay yeah exactly what are they
where does it where does it come from
um I
heard one of his good friends
um they were friends with benefits like
a couple months before we started dating
and she keeps
asking him to hang out and she asked him
to like move in for the week in July and
he didn't like immediately say no to her
he was in the I didn't know if he was
like gonna really tell me about it I
just kind of saw the text come up on his
iPad while we were watching a show
together
um I don't think he would ever do
anything he's never given me a reason
not to trust him but it's just her being
he just goes out with other women on on
work trips
uh this isn't like a work trip friend
it's like one of his friends no I know
you just said he never gives me reasons
to not trust him except the whole reason
you called me is because you're having
trust concerns
so I I I I I you called and so um I am
not inserting myself into this
conversation I I'm I I just want to be
super clear I think there's other things
going on in this relationship
uh and I I have no only thing I have to
base that on is a couple of data points
and maybe I talked to him and he was
just like a lug head who's just like oh
what
um y'all are five you're five months in
and it feels like he's got one foot in
and he has still got another foot out of
the boat that's how I
okay
not a little bit you've been feeling it
a lot and for some reason you minimize
your feelings has that been happening to
your whole life that people you say I
feel this way and people say you're
stupid
um
do you overreact
I think I do
I I mean I usually have to ask people if
I'm overreacting okay
um because I'm not really sure okay so I
want you to get two or three women in
your life that you trust deeply
yeah and if you feel your heart beating
faster or you feel that burn inside your
chest I want you to reach out to one of
them and you know why because I do this
because I'm overreact to things I get
extra mad or extra my feelings hurt so I
want you to have a couple of people in
your pocket that you can ask as you are
learning your own body but let me tell
you this
somebody told you a long time ago to
stop listening to B
and I want you to never do that again I
want you to listen to what your body's
trying to tell you
and if you've been dating a guy for five
months and he's the best guy in the
whole world but he's also still keeping
up with
an old girlfriend that he used to hook
up with regularly or old friend that he
took up with regularly just a few months
before y'all were together and he's
taking women out and not that he's doing
business and trying to do sales
but that he makes you feel stupid he
tries to turn the whole thing back on
you I don't know why you don't trust me
what's the deal he turns it all back on
you without saying yeah I can see that
I think you should trust your gut
something does not feel right if he
wants to call me I'd be happy to talk to
him not like you know yeah bro not that
kind of way but
something doesn't feel right
something doesn't feel right and at some
point soon I think you need to have a
very come to be conversation
and put is there infidelity in this
relationship on the table is there um
gas lighting going on in this
relationship
here is what I feel be very very very
clear about what I feel and more
importantly what I need
and if he can't provide that for you
cool he may not be the guy for you in
fact he won't be the guy for you
this isn't a this isn't a call about
um
sales calls between men and women it's
not that's not the call the call is you
have a guy
that you love who has said he loves you
and these 100 dismissive of how you are
experiencing your relationship with him
that's the red flag we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Ann
Arbor Michigan and talk to Colin what's
up Colin
I'm doing pretty okay I'm uh just
finished up walking with my daughter I
got my second cup of coffee I got my
notebook and uh I'm just really honored
to be here talking to you dude that
sounds like almost the perfect morning
man fantastic so what's up dude
so I'll start with my question I coming
in pretty hot I I survived a suicide
attempts
um about seven years ago
I feel like it connects to me being more
cynical about the world and I want to
change that hmm
well thanks for calling man
um how many little ones do you have
I just got one I got a baby girl who's
nine months old and it's it's the best
that's cool
um
are you able to talk about what happened
seven years ago
yeah tell me about it
so at the time I was in my
well to give you a quick I'll quickly
tell you where I'm at now I'm 29 been
married for four years
I adore my wife I have this nine month
old beautiful baby girl
um and as we enter our 30s as we
purchase our first home I've I just
don't I'm I'm mostly calling about this
event and my cynicism to hopefully
change my my Outlook and not have it rub
off on this sweet baby girl and my wife
um so
I seven years ago I would say honestly
I've had on paper
for the most part a pretty normal
successful uh time as a 20-something so
got my bachelor's degree got my Master's
Degree
um but the kind of blip which I would
say more so is an explosion on that
timeline is it a suicide attempt
um
so is Easter morning actually and I at
the time was in a pretty toxic
relationship
um
was wrestling some with my face uh I
would say I'm a
strong Christian believer now but
certainly had my time of deconstructing
and reconstructing and all that so that
was pretty hairy and
um
just really wrestling this identity
feeling enough
um and that that morning that
relationship ended uh I was actually on
my way to to church and
decided instead to take a left in my car
go the other way
um found a parking lot
just felt this immense emptiness
and
it's kind of something you probably
don't hear every day when it comes to
suicide attempts but I I'm a type 1
diabetic
and I just decided to load up on insulin
and try to overdose that way and end
things so now a conventional
you could say message to family and
friends
hey like I just did this uh
and then
kind of went on a drive around town
while my phone blew up
and I was eventually found in a grocery
parking lot still completely conscious
and fine and rushed to the ER and
thankfully before
all of this happened or I guess before
things got bad
uh I should say
they were able to balance out my blood
sugar
um
you can stop me at any time by the way
well I'm just trying to get a a picture
of
trying to listen for how you're telling
this story
[Music]
um
did you have a history of this before
I didn't that's the thing like it was
it's kind of a snap decision
I don't want to hurt anymore I'm sick of
the world and you have a you have an
opportunity right there with you
yeah and did you ever go into a coma I
didn't hear what you said
I the the hospital
for I don't know what happened because
it was so overwhelming but they uh they
they got things fixed and then I was in
a way for
you know a week or so and
have you had any sort of suicidality
since then an idea of of heading out
again
zero okay
so
um you've done a lot of work over the
last few years huh
I have uh yeah I would say I would say
I'm a very introspective reflective guy
um I think that though is kind of what
got me into that situation was getting
two in my head yeah that's fair but you
haven't touched the core issue
why is there a ticker tape on the story
of your life that runs underneath
everything that goes on in your world
it says I'm a piece of crap
where does that come from
because you've done a lot of work on
relationships and you've done a lot of
work on faith and you've done a lot of
work on doing the right things and
you've probably become pretty
disciplined in your life
you have not addressed the core issue
man
you just have this meta-narrative dude
that you suck where's that from
um
um by the way this has nothing to do
with the suicide attempt
go back and listen to the call like when
you get done like this is about how you
talk about your wife you talk about your
daughter
you think you're a burden to them
where does that come from why do you
think they are worse off because you're
in their life
because it's not true where does that
come from
I would say
I'm sure it's a great question and I'm
trying to think through hold on you are
have created a force field around your
life with your intellect
and your ability to construct and
deconstruct ideas and situations and
people and religions and all that stuff
and it provides you a force field from
having to do one scary thing that is
actually feel something
so I don't want you thinking about it
and going down what's the right words
and what's the right thing
where did you get this story
you know the answer
um I I would say did you grow up in a
super religious household
I did not quite the opposite I mean my
I'm the only believer in my family uh it
was never something
I mean I never heard about any of it
until like I didn't hear about face or
um Christianity until high school so
I didn't find out until after the fact
that my parents disagreed with that and
didn't buy into that
um I'm also a middle child
uh
uh for what that's worth but I am too
we're all kind of a little bit messed up
a little bit messed up
uh here's the thing here's the thing
cynicism
is a bulletproof vest that you put on
to head into your day
so that you don't have to feel
and it protects you from
shame
protects you from looking at that
nine-year-old little girl and being
scared about the economy or whether
China is going to invade or whatever the
news is telling you the next tragedy du
jour is
there's a helpless feeling when you hold
your first baby
there's a helpless feeling that nobody
talks about
because it's either Andrew Tate flexing
or it's it's
this passive nonsense and in the middle
is the rest of us
who's newly married three or four years
in in this woman
hugs us on a couch
with a sense they lean on you
with a weight
that says I put my hands in your life
that has nothing to do with who's making
the most money in the house how you're
splitting up chores it's just a
responsibility that every man I know
feels at some shape form or fashion
and it's really really heavy and our
dads didn't tell us that
um
yeah and it's I would say
it's it's pretty exhausting like because
I don't want to be cynical like I don't
I don't want that for my the these women
in my home no no bro I don't want it for
you
that too I want it for you and if you do
things for them like that all the time
at some point you run out of gas
which is why it's so counterintuitive
when I tell you the path out of this is
you have to say as an identity a new
identity for Colin I reject cynicism I'm
not going there it's a waste of my time
and it destroys me and my family
if you were to ask me uh what I think is
the most profound psychological finding
of the last hundred years I could talk
to you about Amos diversky you talked
about Kahneman all the greats
but it would come back to one thing that
has impacted me personally the most and
that's from Martin Seligman
who does a lot of work on positive
psychology
and basically this the study of
psychology has always been what's the
pathology what's wrong with somebody
and Martin came in and goes why don't we
look at what's right because a whole
bunch of things that are right with
people but there's just one or two
things that people are struggling with
what if we spend our energy working on
what's right and through some of his
experiments what he came to to uncover
that has greatly impacted me
is this
we all thought psychologically speaking
for a hundred or two hundred or maybe
maybe thousands of years I haven't dug
into it that far but that certain people
were EOS they're just born that way
and certain people were just like ah hey
everybody they were just joyful people
and the rest of us fell in some sort of
spectrum
what Seligman comes back and suggests is
that optimism is a learned behavior
pessimism and cynicism is a learned
behavior and when anyone says the words
learned behavior to me
I exchange learned behavior with choice
I choose to look at the most Cosmic
negative way I can look at something
or we all know people
is who someone goes hey man the economy
is about to go down and they're like oh
my gosh it's because of the Republicans
and the Democrats we've got to get a
freezer and we got to play in a garden
it's all coming down and there's those
friends that we have that right there's
gonna be a recession and they smile real
big and they're like dude we're gonna
make millions
that's that's not an operating system
it's a learned behavior it's a choice
and so by you saying I reject cynicism
I'm going to choose optimism I'm going
to choose joy and by the way
um optimism I mean cynicism and
pessimism that's that's our cultural
that's our cultures
um wisdom these days
you and me could probably go round and
round over drinks and have a blast and
you would probably run circles around me
deconstructing Faith because you've been
there in cynicism and pessimism and oh
yeah what about this what about this
that is what our culture calls wisdom
these days and I wholeheartedly reject
that it's nonsense
it's nonsense and so
the only path forward
it's number one you gotta write 22 year
old call in a letter and forgive him for
scaring you to death
um
you gotta you gotta let that dude off
the hook man
he made a rash decision he freaked out
he has heartbroken on Easter morning he
was exhausted and didn't want to hurt
anymore
and he reached over and grabbed the one
thing he had which is insulin pump and
tried to walk out on it
right
yeah and then you got to look at 29 year
old 28 year old Colin and say dude
we're gonna practice optimism
and we're going to reject
cynicism and that means
you can be optimistic and heartbroken
you can be optimistic and scared to
death you can be optimistic and really
frustrated
but that's different than feeling like
my wife when you hold your baby or you
hold your wife and you think I'm so
sorry y'all are stuck with me
tell me if I'm right or if I'm wrong
pure uh you're dead on
um
I I mean relate to so much of what you
just said and
there's like two types of people I can
relate to I have I I have great
that's the thing that's what's so
frustrating up to this point like like
you said how you described me as
disciplined
um doing a lot of work is absolutely
true uh I have great Community like
awesome men in my life I know but you're
the guy you're the guy in those men that
is the architect of the conversations
because that's how you that's how you
defend yourself
I mean you're just putting language to
you're absolutely right yes that's I'm
only laughing because you're dead on so
for the next three three weeks next
three months when you hang out with
those dudes you can't say anything
what you can do is when somebody says
they're they're struggling with
something
they're heartbroken about something
that you look at them and if you want to
be really intentional and weird put your
hand on their shoulder
and say hey man thank you for sharing
that
period no other words
and what you're gonna find is your the
identity you had as the guy with the
answers and the guy with all of the oh
yeah what up because here's the deal
guys like you and me who build these
webs of
of uh of intelligence to protect
ourselves we don't have any thoughts of
Our Own
we don't have any values of our own
because our only value is making sure
you can't ever sit still on your value
because I've got a way to pull it apart
yeah and I'm a few years ahead of you
and I'm telling you you hit a brick wall
because when you're anchorless and you
have no value Anchored In other than I'm
the smartest guy in the room or I can
pull this guy's argument apart or I can
pull this guy's argument apart
then a nine-year-old nine month old
little girl looks at you and says daddy
what's right
your wife looks at you and says hey can
we create
a set of values for this home
and your inside knows my only value is
well they're dumb and that's not
something you can build a home on
and so practicing optimism
practicing and that sounds all Kumbaya
here's what I mean
hey quit watching the news just turn it
off just stop
number two read fiction for a while you
need to detox from
dun dun dun turn podcast off for a while
even mine and mine's incredible by the
way just kidding but you got a detox
from info because what you do is you
listen to an hour podcast like this you
take two of the lines and then you use
that to spread amongst right is that
fair yeah okay
instead start practicing feeling
valuable just because your presence just
because you're there
and what you're going to be surprised is
that people value Colin because Colin
showed up not because Colin listens to
obscure podcasts that nobody's heard of
yeah
and can wrap circles around you know
substitutionary atonement and all the
like you can just do all that right you
know all those things and they don't man
Colin has value
the only path forward manage you gotta
learn to feel and this is the pot
talking of the kettle here
I'm practicing this as we speak it's
hard
do you have can I
I've been on
antidepressants since
that a suicide attempt
and
there's days where I I'll forget to take
them and I just like ball like I I it's
like this whole world has opened up a
Feeling
and
I
I'm also afraid to go off of them though
yeah
it's been seven years
yeah I took sleep medications for seven
years six seven years and I was
terrified to get off
terrified
and I spent months being unable to sleep
scary
totally get him
totally get it
what I would tell you is at some point
you sit down with your doctor and with
your counselor a psychiatrist and you
say
I'm ready to enter into a new phase of
my life
where
I need to come up with some scaffolding
some structure
and we're gonna do this real real real
slow
but I want to learn to feel
and I want to learn some strategies for
feeling
and
that means they're going to have some
really clear suicide plan in case that
that feeling of that urge comes up again
and you're gonna have to commit before
me and your doctors and practitioners
and your friends and family and God that
you will call you will not take your
life
you commit that
oh absolutely I mean I have I have too
much to live for you're 100 exactly so
they're going to come up with some
strategies and plans and then it's just
a stair-step process cool we'll reduce
it by this much for this period of time
we're gonna practice it we're gonna feel
it and yes you're gonna have periods of
of time when you just weep openly
that stuff stored in your body doesn't
go anywhere
there's gonna be periods where you were
super disciplined and now you can't get
out of bed it's gonna be all that's
going to be part of the thing
part of your healing process if that's
what you choose to do but you're gonna
have to this is the Cornerstone you're
gonna have to have people in your corner
you're gonna have to start trying to
over intellectual intellectualize
everything you're gonna just gonna have
to be honest about what you feel
mm-hmm
yeah
is that fear
it's fair I have one
scary stupid question that I want to ask
you out loud like is obvious
it's you don't think it's too late for
me to change my
Outlook
I went to a trauma counselor for the
first time about four months ago
and everything in my life is different
because there's stuff I've never talked
about ever
[Music]
and I'm in my 40s
and I have a seven-year-old little girl
and a 13 year old boy and a woman I've
been married to for 21 years
no
and I've sat with 70 year olds
who decided to change their life and
start lifting weights and start eating a
little different and call their kids and
they say I'm sorry
with the time we got left can we control
all delete and do something new
I do not believe in the phrase it's too
late but I want you to hear the order of
this
start with your wife
take her out to a dinner take her out to
breakfast and say
I'm getting ready to enter into healing
part two
we've been on maintenance for seven
years we feel good we feel safe we feel
secure we got a beautiful kid we got a
great marriage we're heading into part
two and part two is gonna be rough it's
gonna be bumpy
I'd be willing to bet you money if we
had another hour to talk you had some
stuff going on your childhood that is
gnarly
you have to deal with that all right
we'll deal with you
it's part of the journey in the next
conversation after your wife is you're
going to sit down with your doctor
or your counselor or both in a perfect
world and you're going to let everybody
know
I need some coaches and I need some
physician I need some ringside support
because I'm heading into the middle of
the Ring here
and we're going to stair step off this
stuff I'm gonna practice feeling I'm
gonna practice learning I'm going to
practice crying and holding that I'm
going to practice feeling joy for the
first time in a long time I'm going to
practice feeling embarrassment and shame
I'm gonna practice all those things over
the next one two dude this is a this is
a multi-year journey you're on all good
just like lifting weights man
some days you have good workout some
days you don't but over the long haul
you get healthier you feel better and
you can do so much more
I cannot put into words how proud of you
I am calling
this is what bravery and courage and
just straight gangster looks like
the dad his little baby girl and his
wife
dad looking in the mirror saying I'm
worth being well so that I can show up
for these two
that's all I got
I'll walk with you brother every step of
the way here holler at me anytime proud
of you we'll be right back
all right we're back let's go out to
Charlotte and talk to Taylor what's up
Charlotte uh what's up Charlotte what's
up Taylor in Charlotte
Hi how are you good I'm talking to
Charlotte in Taylor North Carolina
what's up what's up Taylor
that I'm having with my husband I'm
sorry I'm really really nervous oh
that's okay you should be because I
don't know any married people that have
communication problems
kind of scary but um so what's up the
main gist of it is sorry
um
that I feel um constantly
ignored about my feelings and my
requests
um especially in matters of like you
know safety and everything for our
daughter yeah tell me about that
um so basically there are there are a
couple of like you know big events that
I know like after binge listening to
your show that I know that there's like
a logical thing that my brain is trying
to do and that my body
is not feeling safe in certain things
but um just like basic things that he
just I can't seem to communicate with
him that are like real safety things
like for instance I know it sounds small
but for me it feels like such a big
thing um like shutting the gate at the
top of the stairs
you know things like that where I'm like
please shut the gate at the top of the
stairs like this is very important our
daughter is extraordinarily hyperactive
she beelines it for the stairs I really
need you to shut the gate to the point
where he doesn't listen he doesn't
actually follow through and I I've had
to put signs up like please do this like
as a reminder and it still doesn't
happen where else where else does he not
show up
um
he just
his communication he knows that he's bad
at communication he recognizes that and
I'll I'm very blunt and I'll point it
out I feel like you're not communicating
with me well and then we'll have like a
good stretch of like a a couple weeks
where he tries and then he just
completely waves off so just the way
that he speaks to me he speaks to other
people where he doesn't realize when it
comes off as cold Taylor
you how long have you been with him
uh eight years we've been married for
five okay you have been covering for him
and protecting him a long time
and you curated the staircase thing
which by the way is a big deal
if you've ever been to a house where a
toddler's gone tumbling down the stairs
it is not funny it is a big deal
but you picked that story
and lieu of other ones because you've
defended this guy for a long time
give me an example of where he's not
safe
and be honest
I'm right right I wonder
no no no no no
defending him on this call he's a grown
man
okay
um
he has a bad habit of like whenever I do
Point those things out to him that are
unfavor that he's getting too angry or
trying to argue with me in front of our
daughter I try to remove her from the
situation
and there was a situation and it was it
feels so stupid because it was months
ago but um I was upstairs getting ready
to go to work and I heard my daughter
crying and it wasn't like a normal cry
like a mom knows when a cry isn't normal
and I know that she can be very
difficult during you know like dinner
time and things like that this is like
right before she turned two
and I came down the stairs and he didn't
see that I was right there and he was so
angry at her for not wanting to eat her
food that he grabbed her leg and shook
it and like cried out in anger and the
first thing I did I ran over I wasn't
yelling or shouting because I was just
trying to get my hysterical scared
daughter out of there and I picked her
up and I swooped her up and I was like
we are we are leaving we are going
upstairs I'm separating this is this is
not happening and I grabbed her and she
was cleaning to me and I took her
upstairs
and he followed us upstairs he's like no
don't take her away I'm so so sorry I'm
so sorry I was like no we need space we
need space she needs space and he
followed me up the stairs and healing
would not leave us alone like he
wouldn't stop and I tried to go into our
bedroom
and he was trying to get into the room
and I had her on my hip and I'll try and
close the door and lock it so that way
we could just get the space for her to
calm down
and he repeatedly hit me with the door
while I was holding her and I was like
you're hurting me you're gonna hurt her
and he was like then you need to let me
in you have to let me in let me
apologize to her I'm sorry you have to
let me apologize to her and I was like
please like you're scaring us like
you're scaring her she's crying and he
repeatedly slammed the door and then I
finally got enough leverage against the
bed to shut it and lock it and he just
like wept out in the hallway and then
after like an hour I finally felt okay
for him to see her again and he like
wept over her he felt awful he's never
done anything like this before he's
never hit me he's never hit her
or anything he's all awful
and he was like I'm so sorry that will
never happen again but
I feel like I let it I let it go too
easy and now everything's like bubbling
up where I'm just like seeing things
like a gate being left open and I just I
lose my mind hold on you should Taylor
because you're not safe
and
I'm you've listened to the show you said
for a while you know I am
as forgiving as they come when people do
something stupid it happens to all of us
right and we live in a world now where a
teacher can be perfect just do great
work for 20 years and then she pops off
and says one thing and then she's fired
like that's the world we're in I don't
want to participate in that world
but when someone is violent with a child
followed up by violence with his wife
and here's the concern
there is a rage that is scary
but there is a self-centeredness
I will hurt you so that I can make
myself feel better by saying sorry
and here's the big deal to me
somebody snaps they get scream at their
kid they whatever
I used to tell my students all the time
doing something stupid in a moment does
not mean you have bad character where
I'm going to look for character is what
happens immediately afterwards
and there's been no change no I need to
go see somebody no will you forgive me
no contriteness no hey how do I love you
better today how do I love you better
today
there's been a hey man it's cool it was
it was a wild night wasn't it
and now we're back to old Taylor
I mean we're back to old household
and if you go back and listen to this
call you've apologized for your daughter
being loud she's two years old for God's
sakes
you've apologized for you you've
apologized for
you have all of the the
um vocal mannerisms of someone who's in
a very abusive unsafe situation
I believe you I believe you when you say
he's never done this before or after I
believe you
that your body is running on Razor's
Edge right
yeah
I know that he loves me and like he is
I don't know where it came from I just I
he's such a
a good guy and he's he tries like he
goes through these big stages of like of
really really trying Taylor Taylor
Taylor really really trying is not
enough here
it's not enough
you change
if you're trying to fix your car and all
you have in your tool kit is a hammer
and you smash the engine to pieces
you immediately
resolve to a go get new tools because
you don't have the right tools to fix
this thing
and B get somebody to teach you how to
do it
and infinitely more important than a
stupid car engine is a daughter and a
wife
yeah
and I'm telling you right now Taylor I
I'm
gonna honor your silence here
I'm gonna honor your silence
and what I say about that is I've been
prying a little bit and you don't want
to talk and that about some of them
that's fine
I know you're not safe
and whatever that looks like
he's never I I I will say this like ever
since that moment
he's he's never even so much just like
raised his voice at our daughter like
you know you know he did he unplugged
instead of solving the problem he
detached from it
so instead of being a rageful angry guy
now he's numb
and he won't even lock the gate he won't
even do small basic things to keep your
daughter safe to make you feel loved to
make you feel safe inside your own home
because he's so untrustful of himself
that he can't plug back in and listen I
applaud him for unplugging for a second
but at some point he's gotta be a dad
and be a husband
right and
it was just so crazy because like he had
never even if he's never ever raised a
hand at me he's never violently like
shouted at me or anything like that
before and I asked him I was like is
there like something going on okay let's
do this let's do this
he did what he did right
yeah and
you and I both know
that maybe not in that it's that type of
wild evening
there have been other things that make
you feel unsafe
here's what's important you can't
control his actions or his thoughts you
can't
there's not some magic thing you haven't
said
there's not some like oh man if I had
just done this then maybe he would
he's making choices he's an adult
at the end of the day you are going to
have to decide
what your boundaries and what safety
looks like for you
you're gonna have to communicate them in
a very direct and clear way
here's what I mean
I mean you take him out to lunch or take
him out to breakfast and you start the
conversation with this is going to be a
very hard conversation
and if you lose your temper or you get
angry
I am going to leave
if you tell me that what my feelings are
are my feelings are stupid I'm Gonna
Leave
I need you to listen directly to me
without responding can you do that and
if he's a grown-up he'll say yes then
you tell him I have not been able to
come back from what happened a few
months ago a few weeks ago
I still haven't taken a full breath
I still can't but uh I haven't done
anything I know I know this is me
I can't breathe
and so the only path forward I see for
us right now is that you and I go see a
marriage counselor ASAP
and I've already got us an appointment
if you don't go
I hear you telling me you are not
interested in being married to me
if you do go I hear you saying you're
very sorry about what happened and
you're willing to learn new tools so
that we can create a great family
together
do you hear what I'm saying Taylor
that's how Direct
yeah
if you go in and you're like well I'm so
sorry that she didn't want to eat that
night no she's two of course
two-year-olds don't eat every night
they're just bundles of nerves
yeah I feel like
honestly like you're right and I've
he always says like you know we even
talked about I asked him like after the
incident happened I I came downstairs
and I was surprisingly very calm after I
put my daughter to bed and I was I I
threatened him and I was like if this
ever happens again I will I will leave
you I will take my daughter
and we will leave
I'll say it doesn't matter how much I'm
in love with you but we will go and I
feel like that that scared him into not
doing anything like I said he he adores
he adores her he really does that's why
I feel like it just came out of the blue
and I don't know what happened but it
isn't the first time that I feel like
his feelings
you know of what he's feeling in that
moment of my safety is is disregarded
and you know like in the questions that
I that I wrote you guys it obviously
your body is telling you something and
it leaks into the attraction of your
marriage
because your body you like can look at
your husband and be like wow he is you
know excuse me like he is so hot but
like my body is like no I don't I don't
feel as comfortable as I should yeah
here's the thing I think you know as
well as I do
this marriage has way more problems than
you have ever wanted to say publicly out
loud
I think it's going to be really
important for you to take a yellow path
and start writing stories down
one after the other
and I know there are good stories too
you'll talk about that with your
counselor but I want you to take stories
I want you to write them down one after
another after another after another
because I think if you look at them out
of your body on a piece of paper you're
going to find one of two things there's
been two or three big blow-ups over the
course of your marriage
that need to be addressed they have to
be addressed
or you're going to find 30 or 40.
you're gonna realize oh my gosh my
body's been trying to get my attention
for eight years
because we're not safe I'm not safe now
I brought a baby girl into this and
she's not safe
[Music]
you're gonna have to write down what you
need you have to write down what you
want you have to write down what your
boundaries are and you have to
communicate them directly and remember
this behavior is a language if he loves
you and he loves that little girl and
he's all in on creating something
extraordinary a life together it'll be
all in
if he walks away
he's telling you everything you need to
hear
thank you so much for the call Taylor
I'm so so sorry we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
this
Kelly just got this tattoo under her the
front of her neck
by her favorite band The Disturbed
and the tattoo is incredible songs
called the light and he goes like this
like an unsung Melody the truth is
waiting there for you to find it it's
not a blight but a remedy a clear
reminder of how it began deep inside
your memory you turned away as you
struggled to find it you heard it call
as you walked away when you think all is
forsaken listen to me now hopes not
forsaken you never you need never feel
broken again sometimes Darkness can show
you the light
thank you guys I love you all stay in
school don't do drugs bye